we have a new education secretary Donald
Trump's election for education secretary
Betsy DeVos was confirmed yesterday with
a historic tie breaking vote from the
vice president of the United States Mike
Pence needed to break a 50-50 tie let's
take a look at the historic moment on
this vote the yeas are 50 the nays are
50 the Senate being equally divided the
Vice President votes in the affirmative
and the nomination is confirmed
majority leader I'm going to reconsider
the vote on the nomination and just like
that weeks of advocacy against this
horrible horrible choice to lead the
country's education goes by the wayside
there were two Republicans that voted
against Betsy DeVos as confirmation and
that's all fine well and good but the
real news here is that the confirmation
of Betsy DeVos to Education Secretary
proves you can buy into government power
in the United States you can even if you
have no business being there and up
there by sheer virtue of having a lot of
money Betsy DeVos has no business
heading up education for the United
States she was embarrassed I don't know
three four five times during her
confirmation hearings by Tim Kaine by Al
Franken by Elizabeth Warren didn't
matter an Al Franken sort of asked the
key question during those hearings would
you be here if your family hadn't
donated roughly two hundred million
dollars to politicians the answer is
obviously a resounding no she is only
there because of her family's political
contributions I mean unfortunately
political patronage has been around for
a long time probably peaked in the 1880s
with a spoil system but usually the
contributions would be in exchange for
like an ambassadorship or something not
something as brazen as Secretary of
Education yeah I mean Obama sold a ton
of ambassador ships to the big bundlers
that raised a ton of money for him
that's nothing new but very clearly here
Betsy DeVos buying her way into the
cabinet she was asked whether she
opposes guns in school Rachel she cited
non-existent grizzly bear attacks as a
reason to maybe
have guns in schools she didn't agree
that schools that receive federal money
should have to follow the individuals
with disabilities in Education Act this
is someone who has no clue whatsoever
about education she couldn't even
understand really simple questions about
education including from Senator Al
Franken
never mind put together an even remotely
informed answer she has actually
admitted that her family bought
influence with her donations check out
something that she said previously which
I'll put up on the screen for you this
is from a 1997 op-ed for roll call that
she wrote my family is the largest
single contributor of soft money through
the National Republican Party I have
decided however to stop taking offense
at the suggestion that we are buying
influence the piece reads now I simply
concede the point we expect to foster a
conservative governing philosophy
consisting of limited government and
respect for traditional American virtues
we expect a return on investment we
expect a good and honest government
furthermore we expect the Republican
Party to use the money to promote these
policies and yes to win elections well
she bought influence Rachael she did it
she won I guess yeah she she definitely
won what I've kind of been hearing a lot
of overwhelming response is that a lot
of parents are worried that she is going
to take away the measures that are put
in place for communications between
parents and students which a lot of
people I think if I Delta Kappa pull
said that about two-thirds of parents
gave their public schools a grade of an
A or a B and then one-third it was about
a C or a D but what kind of
overwhelmingly showed satisfaction was
the communication and a lot of people
are worried that she's going to divert
money away from putting in places aides
and therapists who really bolster that
communication oh yeah I mean she doesn't
even conceptually support the concept of
just funding public schools and all of
those aspects are going to suffer she
wants to effectively create Christian
schools that's really what her mission
is Pat she wants to quote advance God's
kingdom we talked about that last time
we discussed Betsy DeVos and there's
people writing to me saying well why
couldn't john mccain increasingly the
republican voice of reason
at least vote against her well she
bought him to her
family contributed over fifty thousand
dollars to John McCain during the thirty
six year period starting in 1980 what
about Marco Rubio who sometimes is a
Republican with a spine he took a
combined hundred thousand bucks from
Betsy Davos and her family did vote to
confirm her that's at least partially
why they didn't vote against her and we
criticize Betsy DeVos because she
doesn't have any experience with public
schools but I think that's kind of the
whole point I think that's why she was
put into this position because it's very
hard to get rid of a department and the
next best thing is to just put someone
in charge that doesn't even agree with
it
to understand this and I wanted to touch
on that next you have to understand the
position of some of the Republicans
voting YES and many of their
constituents they want to destroy public
education in this country that's exactly
what Betsy DeVos wants to do the reasons
are stick religion in school that's one
reason to put Betsy DeVos in and take
money away from public schools and to
private schools in that sense it makes
perfect sense that a lot of these
Republicans would support her that's how
they see education Rachel they want
public education to go that way yeah I'm
just also thinking that her unilateral
power won't even be completely strong so
she's actually in a perfect position
yeah absolutely this perpetuates the
circle you defund public schools because
they're bad they get worse because
you've defunded them which then you use
to justify taking even more money away
if you have here's my word of
encouragement to the kids out there stay
in school kids if you have two hundred
million dollars and you're at all
worried you might not be able to be I
don't know Secretary of Housing and
Urban Development because you don't know
anything about it
Betsy DeVos --is riches to riches story
can be a huge inspiration for you
because the two hundred million bucks
can get you into the cabinet damn it Pat
you can do it too that's the American
dream isn't it yeah basically is buying
power with money you've inherited from
your family